that sort of told us two things I think
one is we went back and analyzed the
data and both times when we sort of
peakin infection there was an opening in
the sea ice on the Russian side so we
think that the introduction of virus was
associated with lower sea ice and then
the second thing that this told us is
that now that the ice is opened more
often we're wondering if this type of
movement of pathogens with animals could
become more common
the reason they could move further we
think is because the ice was open they
used to be in a land bridge at the ice
formed so that these different
populations could not come in contact
with each other but as the ice is
reducing there's many openings now and
they might be more moving further
because they might be looking for food
so as the Arctic warms the fish go
deeper and also maybe go further
offshore so animals are having to move
further to find food and as a result of
that are coming in contact with other
species that they probably never used to
but probably transmitted through
respiratory droplets so when animals get
sick they're coughing on each other and
then also by direct contact so we think
that the seals are able to give it to
each other when they come up on land and
they come in close contact or when
they're feeding at sea because of course
many different species will feed
together at sea when there's a large
school of fish there's polar bears
potentially are becoming extinct because
of the fact that they rely on seals for
food and as business ice they have to
travel much further to try to find their
food so people eventually will have the
same issues if they are subsisting on
these animals and having a hard time
finding them because there's less ice
for them to hunt on or the animals of
further offshore beyond where they
normally hunt so I think as already
changes and the environments being
affected the animals are being affected
which in turn will affect the livelihood
of people living up there
the virus is probably already in the
Artic so there's not really a way of
stopping it the question is trying to
figure out which species might be most
vulnerable and how to protect them
because you know you can't really
vaccinate really large numbers you know
they are these really big it's very
remote and it's not realistic to think
you can access enough animals to protect
them
[Music]
you